lyon pendant l'été les châteaux de la
loire accueille des centaines de
milliers de visiteurs et pour augmenter
encore leurs chiffres de fréquentation
nombre d'entre eux propose des sons et
lumières oui c'est le cas de
d'azay-le-rideau qui pour la sixième
année consécutive propose les
imaginaires il s'agit d'une balade
nocturne dans les jardins du château
balade au cours de laquelle le
spectateur et replonger dans l'époque
des fastes de la renaissance l'année
dernière le spectacle attiré trente
mille spectateurs on voit ça avec
béatrice blondeau et patrice sont
majeurs azay-le-rideau somnolent encore
mais dans quelques instants
le belle endormie s'éveillera comme tous
les soirs d'été le château s'anime pour
un son et lumière
nous sommes au début du 16e siècle à
l'époque de la renaissance
ce soir il y a six cents visiteurs des
touristes essentiellement qui ont envie
d'être surpris en une voix quelque chose
de beau et qui laisse libre cours à
notre imagination
je le dis tous les imaginaires et le
miracle commence grâce à l'outil
principal de ce spectacle un savon jeux
d'ombré et de lumière
et le spectateur devient acteur ici on a
le droit d'entrer dans le décor comme
dans cette salle de balle virtuelle ou
dans ce magnifique jardin à la française
reconstitués à l'identique
mais la renaissance c'est aussi la
période à laquelle on découvre les
planètes matérialiser aussi par des
boules de verre ici le spectateur fait
un voyage dans le temps grâce aux
techniques modernes les visiteurs
découvrent un musée vivant c'est moi
l'histoire de france qu'ils ont envie de
rencontrer cantons lorsqu'ils visitent
ces châteaux quelque chose qui n'est pas
une nostalgie justement mais qui est
plus la vie de la vie de cet endroit de
ce château à travers de temps
aujourd'hui et pour cette famille venue
découvrir le spectacle
le miracle s'est produit attention à
tout instant et moi on est vraiment à
l'epo leur naissance peut-être pas mais
dans un autre monde jouer peut-être plus
des personnages pendant quelques heures
le temps semble suspendre son vol
les spectateurs eux ont jusqu'au 23
septembre pour se plonger dans la féerie
d'azay-le-rideau
oh